Ich bin von da vorne gekommen,
und ich dachte mir schon,
dass es wahrscheinlich irgendwas
jetzt mit Corona zu tun hat.
Ich dachte erst, es ginge um Sonderangebote
eines Geschäfts, wegen der Farben.
Das ist ‘ne Gruppe von verschiedenen
Menschen, Frauen, Männern,
Kindern, sogar Tiere.
Aber wir laufen halt alle
auch mit Masken rum,
und man erkennt sich nicht mehr wirklich.
Ja, es ist bunt und erfreut einem das Herz,
muss ich wirklich sagen.
Das ist im Prinzip ja auch das,
was uns fehlt, ja.
11 Uhr am Vormittag vor dem Kölner Dom.
111 Schaufensterfiguren baut der Künstler
Dennis Josef Meseg mit seinem Team
auf dem Roncalli-Platz auf.
„It Is like it is“ hat er seine Installation genannt
– zu Deutsch: „Es ist wie es ist“.
Ein Sinnbild für die Corona-Pandemie und
deren gesellschaftliche Auswirkungen.
Es steht für die Bewegungseinschränkungen,
die wir zu Corona-Zeiten haben.
Dass wir halt nicht das tun können,
uns nicht so bewegen können,
wie wir es gewohnt sind,
wie wir es gerne hätten.
Weil wir sehen gerade in Krisenzeiten,
wie sich unser Leben ändern kann und
Errungenschaften, die wir als
selbstverständlich empfunden haben,
auf einmal in so weite Ferne rücken.
Die Domplatte in Köln ist
einer von vielen Orten,
an denen der Künstler
seine Puppen inszeniert.
Seit Beginn der Pandemie
im vergangenen Jahr
sind diese bereits durch mehr
als 30 deutsche Städte getourt.
Unter anderem machten sie
vor dem Berliner Reichstag halt,
eroberten Potsdam
und besetzten die
Alte Lahnbrücke in Limburg.
Die in rot-weißes Flatterband
eingewickelten Figuren
symbolisieren die soziale Distanz und den
Stillstand des öffentlichen Lebens.
Selbst auf einer Skipiste.
Ja, die Figuren kommen aus
allen Himmelsrichtungen.
Die kommen zum Beispiel auch aus
Boutiquen - aus allen Richtungen,
die ihre Pforten geschlossen
haben über die Corona-Zeit.
Aber auch ein Hobbybaumarkt,
der zumachen musste.
Dort konnte ich dann alle Figuren für ‘nen
sehr vernünftigen Preis erwerben.
Dennis Josef Meseg studiert an der „Alanus
Hochschule für Kunst und Gesellschaft“
in der Nähe von Bonn.
Sein Spezialgebiet sind Skulpturen
aus Materialien wie Holz,
das er mit einer Kettensäge bearbeitet,
oder Metallkonstruktionen.
"It is like it is" ist seine
erste öffentliche Installation.
Noch in diesem Jahr soll ein Fotoband über
die Schaufensterpuppen erscheinen,
die stellvertretend das erleben, was vielen
während der Pandemie nicht möglich ist.
Sie gehen in Clubs,
machen gesellige Bar-Abende
oder einen Ausflug in den Zoo.
Zuletzt feierten die Puppen
in Köln ausgiebig Karneval,
der zum Bedauern
vieler Jecken ausfallen musste.
Zum Vergleich:
So sah das noch im vergangenen Jahr aus.
Dass die tourende Installation unabhängig
von ruhenden Kunst- und Kulturbetrieben
stattfinden kann, ist nicht nur Glück,
sondern auch Botschaft.
Ja, Kunst und Kultur ist natürlich
auch was fürs Oberstübchen.
Was man vielleicht gar nicht
bewusst so mitbekommt,
was einen geistig anregt, inspiriert,
auch in anderen Lebensbereichen,
und das merkt man jetzt vielleicht irgendwie,
dass einem das halt irgendwie fehlt.
Im Mai wird Dennis Josef Meseg
für „It is like it is“ mit dem
Kreativitätspreis CREO
in Zürich ausgezeichnet.
Und wenn es die Pandemie zulässt,
will er mit seinen Schaufensterpuppen
bald auch durch andere Länder touren.